hi in this video I would talk about
phase 2 by transformation reaction and
phase 2 biotransformation reaction
occurs in the cell after phase 1
biotransformation reaction phase 1
biotransformation reaction I have talked
earlier are really performed by
hydroxylation reaction and by addition
of sulfide royal group or amino group
now in the phase 2 biotransformation
reaction main reactions are conjugation
type reaction so with the product of the
phase 1 reaction some type of chemical
groups are conjugated so that it could
become more soluble and could be easily
excreted by urine
so first reaction would be
glucuronidation so one good example is
bilirubin bilirubin is conjugated with
glucuronic acid and it get excreted so
unconjugated bilirubin is insoluble but
when it's conjugate with glue chloride
it becomes soluble and it could be
excreted easily and glucuronic acid
could conjugate with hydroxyl carbonyl
oils or sulfide drug group
so remember hydroxyl sulfide drug or
carbonyl group would be present in a
particular drug or xenobiotic after the
phase 1 biotransformation reaction
because phase 1 biotransformation
reaction basically adds hydroxyl group
or sulfide rail group and the key
example the key enzyme used in this
process of decolonization is UDP glucose
o'neil transferase so it's a transfers
enzyme it would transfer blue chloride
group and it is mainly present in
endoplasmic reticulum next example would
be so here is our drug and we have UDP
blue chronic acid and by the enzyme you
typically Coronel transfer is this
glucuronic acid group would be
transferred on to the hydroxyl group of
this particular drug
and this drug was by transformed in the
phase one reaction so here we have a
detailed example so here we have aspirin
which is a non-steroidal
anti-inflammatory drug
so this aspirin after phase one reaction
a cured a hydroxyl group on this
hydroxyl group Glu kronite conjugation
can take place
so in this hydroxyl group you do pick
blue coral transferase adds these blue
coronoid group as you can see there are
many negative charges in this blue
coronoid conjugate so as there are many
negative charge this is highly polar and
water soluble so it could be easily
excreted from the system and then
another important phase to
biotransformation reaction is
glutathione conjugation and glutathione
conjugation is really important
glutathione conjugation takes place in
all alkyl halide epoxide and alkanes
and here is our drug which is actually
bio transformed and it has now alkyl
halide group represented that as X now
glutathione would be attached to this
group and as you remember glutathione is
a tripeptide which is gamma glutamine
become a glutamine cysteine eyes lysine
so it has a pyramid cysteine and glycine
so it's a tripeptide
now after conjugation of the glutathione
the drug would be conjugated with
glutathione by glutathione transferase
GST it's a very important enzyme after
that these particular glutathione
conjugated drug would react with the
acceptor and the acceptor would accent
the gamma glutamate group and now it
would leave the glycine I'll cysteine
conjugate of form of the drug and this
glycine I'll cysteine glycine an
existing conjugation of this drug is
further processed by peptidase where the
glycine is removed and there is a
cysteine group only
present and after that in acetyl
transferase transfers a acetyl group so
here you can see this is the basic
cysteine and after that n acetyl
transferase transfer actually the acetyl
group and whatever you can see now this
is actually the markup uric acid and
markup Sharik acid is highly soluble so
here you can see it is actually a
cysteine group with which acetyl group
is added and so it became markup uric
acid and markup uric acid is soluble it
could be excreted easily another type of
important biotransformation reaction of
phase 2 is sulphate conjugation now
sulphate conjugation takes place when
there is a presence of phenolic or
alcoholic groups and sulfate group
transfer sulphate group sulfate group is
transferred from phosphor adenosine
phosphor transparent transparence which
is called BAPS so phosphor adenosine
phosphor sulphate is BAPS
and the transfer is reaction actually
transfer perhaps the sulfate group from
BAPS to the particular drug and make it
more soluble another important
biotransformation reaction is
acetylation so its acetylation means
basically conjugation with acetic acid
and this acetyl group the source of this
acetyl group is as tell cooing drugs
like isoniazid sulfanilamide like
sulphur drugs are eliminated by
eliminated in this acetylated form so
acid i relation is also very important
phase to biotransformation reaction so
thats conclude the video on phase 2 by
transformation reaction I hope you
enjoyed the video if you liked my video
give it a big thumbs up don't forget to
subscribe and please leave your comments
below thank you